nationally Democrats call anyone who
disagrees with our immigration views a
bigot in California they've gone way
beyond that California Attorney General
Xavier Becerra is threatening employers
with prosecution if they collaborate
with their own federal government in
enforcing immigration law Travis Allen
is caught right in the middle is he's a
California State Assemblyman but a curse
now is a lawyer and serves on the u.s.
Commission on civil rights and has spent
a lot of time thinking about the
question of immigration they both join
us tonight thanks a lot for coming on
both of you so mr. Allen - you first
are we overstating it or does it seem
like one of those moments where the
union begins to fall apart when you're
Attorney General says he's gonna
prosecute Californians for a baying
federal law that seems a big deal to me
this is a very big deal I mean this goes
far beyond just legislators trying to
make California sanctuary state now
you're looking at the Attorney General
literally with criminally criminally
trying to obstruct justice
he is instructing California business
owners that if you try to comply with
federal immigration law you will be
prosecuted under state law he's crossed
the line this is now a criminal offense
Department of Justice needs to come
sessions and Trump need to come to
California
literally arrests indict Xavier Becerra
for breaking federal law seems like
maybe a bigger deal than other things
are worried about named Washington mr.
Carson you got to kind of wonder who is
being served by these policies Harvard
has kind of an amazing new study out on
attitudes toward immigration and it
shows that african-american voters are
among the most conservative on this 85%
of black voters polled by Harvard said
you should not be allowed to come to the
United States unless you are bringing
skills or money with you that's
considered a fringe view in Washington
why is this not better known these views
not better known because there's a
political imperative in making sure that
this kind of information has not gotten
out there if you take a look at all of
the studies that show who is affected
most an adversary adverse way by illegal
immigration without question and by far
it's black Americans particularly black
males 40% of the 18 point decline in
black employment levels is due to
illegal immigration we're talking if you
do the math of over a million people who
don't have jobs because of illegal
immigration
the competition that comes from that but
it goes beyond simply the economic
aspect of this which is devastating
we're talking about family formation
issues and concentration issues to take
California for example it's very
difficult to get this kind of data
because public officials guard this data
more tenaciously than nuclear launch
codes but trying to get crime data on
illegal immigrants and we've done it
we've we've spent a copious amount of
time laborious league disaggregating
information there's at least two
thousand four hundred thirty illegal
aliens in California prisons today due
to murder John lot has done a study
showing that illegal aliens and
especially daca age illegal aliens are
245 percent more likely to commit all
manner of crimes than our lawful
residents that kind of statistic we've
looked at at the Civil Rights Commission
my assistant and I and Special Counsel
have looked at this kind of information
and have seen that on average we're
talking about the states where we can
find this data mainly the writer states
like New York Florida Texas Arizona and
California we're looking at at least 60%
more likely if you're an illegal limit
to have committed a crime of any nature
but many of those crimes are of the most
horrific nature then are lawful
residents this visits horrific
implications upon those vulnerable
communities one of the keys is the black
community well and you'd think we would
have a debate about a Travis Allen are
these figures discussed at all in the
state of California by your media there
you know unfortunately they are not you
know they're entirely overlooked and
everyone is trying to make this about
immigration when what we're really
talking about is illegal immigration and
you know in California we've got the
sanctuary state so this is not even
people who have come here legally this
is people who have come here illegally
and then are committing crimes while
they're here and then they're being paid
for and defended with taxpayer dollars
and then now on top of this I mean
really is if that wasn't enough now
Xavier Becerra is threatening every
California business owner again you know
if you try to comply with federal law if
you comply with federal authorities
doing their constitutional duty he is
going to prosecute you under California
law we're talking criminal prosecution
fines of ten thousand dollars or
potentially even more
and this is how far it's gone in
California road tests if you have made
your own entries long yeah that's
unbelievable chuckling thank you both so
yeah thank you I appreciate it